Guten Tag.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz-Selzentätich und würde gerne heute mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschritt führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Jürgen Meier.
Herr Meier, könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vorname buchstabieren?
Ja, also J-U-R-G-E-N.
Jürgen Meier mit E-V-E-Mail.
Meier mit E-V-E-Mail, ja.
Okay. Herr Meier, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 76 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau geworden?
25.6.1946.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,72 m groß.
Und wie schwer wiegen Sie zur Zeit?
Wie schwer bin ich?
Ich bin momentan 70 kg schwer.
Okay, Herr Meier, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Also ich habe seit ungefähr einer Woche Schmerzen beim Schlucken.
Und ich kann nicht mehr richtig essen.
Seit einer Woche.
Davor waren Sie ganz gesund, oder?
Hatten Sie noch beschwerden?
Also ich hätte keine Schmerzen beim Schlucken.
Und Essen war unproblematisch.
Unproblematisch, okay.
Sowohl mit festen Essen als auch wie flüssigen Essen.
Beide, für beide.
Ja, für beide. Ich konnte ganz normal essen, ja.
Sie haben seit einer Woche Schmerzen beim Schlucken.
Und könnten Sie diese Schmerzen ein bisschen beschreiben?
Sie haben Brennen, Dumfe oder so etwas?
Also das sind so brennende Schmerzen.
Wenn ich etwas runterschlucke, egal ob fest oder flüssig, das brennt wie Feuer.
Okay.
Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 bedeutet sehr stark Schmerzen.
Also ich würde sagen, dass es zu 6 bis 7, wenn ich schlucke.
Okay, beim Schlucken.
Äußerschlucken, haben Sie bei Ruhe auch Schmerzen?
Nein, so habe ich keine Schmerzen, nur beim Schlucken.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch etwas beschwerden, wie Fieber, Appetitlosigkeit, Gewichtsverlust oder etwas anderes?
Ja, gut. Wichtig, ein bisschen runtergegangen.
Aber Appetitlos bin ich nicht, ich kann nur nicht Schlucken plötzlich.
Wie viel Kilogramm haben Sie abgenommen in wie viel Zeitraum?
Also ich habe ungefähr 6 Kilo jetzt in der einen Woche verloren.
Okay.
In einer Woche haben Sie 6 Kilo Abgenomen.
Hat es Fieber, Hermann?
Fieber hatte ich nicht, nein.
Nachtschweiß?
Nachtschweiß habe ich auch nicht, nein.
Okay.
Hatten Sie diese Beschwerden oder einige Beschwerden früher?
Früher habe ich solche Beschwerden nicht gehabt, nein.
Okay, haben Sie andere Beschwerden, zum Beispiel Beschwerden mit Sturgang oder Wasallasen
oder Schlafstörungen oder noch etwas anderes?
Schlafstörungen habe ich nicht, nein.
Und mit Sturgang, ja, seit ungefähr 10 Tagen, hat der sich ein bisschen dunkel verfährt.
Dunkel verfährt.
Braun oder schwarz, können Sie beschreiben?
Ich habe es jetzt nicht kontrolliert, aber für mich sah es so Richtung schwarz aus.
Haben Sie Verstopfung?
Ich kann nicht hören, einen Moment.
Soweit, dann habe ich ein Mikrofon kaputt.
Pardon.
Also eher schwarz, aber ich habe es nicht genau kontrolliert, gestohlen gar.
Sie haben dann keine Verstopfung oder die Röhr?
Nein, was ist die Röhr?
Die Röhr ist Durchfall.
Ah, immer ein Durchfall.
Nein, Durchfall habe ich nicht, eher ein bisschen fest, aber Verstopfung würde ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Normaler wie früher, wie vorher.
Normaler wie vorher.
Okay, und beim Wasallasen haben Sie kein Problem?
Nein, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Okay, Herr Maia.
Haben Sie wichtig, gefordert, können Sie zum Beispiel Blutzucker oder Bluthochdruck etwas anders?
Also Bluthochdruck habe ich nicht und Blutzucker habe ich auch nicht.
Nur, ich habe seit Jahren so Räume beschwerben.
Meine Kniegelenke und meine Handgelenke tun weh.
Seit ungefähr drei Monaten nehme ich Cortison ein.
Seit drei Monaten.
Welche Diagnose wurde bei Ihnen gestellt?
Rheumatoide Arthritis.
Nehmen Sie etwas anderes ein, regelmäßig?
Also wie gesagt, Cortison hat mir mein Rheumatologe verordnet
und daneben nehme ich noch Schmerzmittel ein, momentan Ibuprofen,
also 3 mal 400 Millikram.
In dieser Woche oder bei Bedarf?
Also schon die ganze Zeit.
Hilft diese Ibuprofen beim Errern, Beschwerden, beim Schlucken?
Gegen die Schlucken? Nein, aber die Glenschmerzen,
natürlich die Schmerzen sind besser.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert, Herr Maya?
Nein, bisher wurde ich nicht operiert, nein.
Und sind Sie gegen etwas allergisch?
Allergien, ja, gegen Gräser, Pollen, aber sonst wüsste ich nicht.
Wie äußert sich diese Allergie aus?
Das ist ja meistens im Frühjahr, wenn die Gräser blühen,
dann kriege ich heftigsten Schnupfen, die Augen werden rot
und teilweise kriege ich dann Probleme mit der Luft.
Nehmen Sie etwas Medikamente dagegen in diesem Jahreszeit?
Ja, wenn es sehr heftig wird, hatte mir mein Allergologe
Tabletten aufgeschrieben, so Tavagil heißen die, glaube ich.
Okay, Tavagil, ich verstehe.
Gibt es irgendwelche wichtige Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie
bei der Mutter oder beim Vater?
Also ist mir nicht bekannt, weder bei meinem Vater noch bei meiner Mutter.
Die waren eigentlich relativ alt geworden
und hatten keine so richtigen Erkrankungen gehabt, nein.
Sind Sie noch im Leben oder sind Sie verstorben?
Nein, nein, die sind schon verstorben. Ich bin ja schon 76.
Die wären ja 100 mehr, so als sind sie nicht geworden.
Die Mutter ist vor 20 Jahren verstorben
und mein Vater war vor 10 Jahren, müsste es jetzt her sein, als er gestorben ist.
Und woran sind Sie verstorben? Erinnern Sie sich daran?
Soweit ich im Kopf habe, hatte die Mutter irgendeine Lungenentwünnung
oder so und war damit im Krankenhaus, hat es dann nicht geschafft.
Und mein Vater, der hatte, glaube ich, irgendwie so etwas Ähnliches wie ein Schlaganfall
und ist da dran gestorben.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder, der ist so 10 Jahre jünger als ich.
Ist er gesund?
Der hat, glaube ich, mit Diabetes zu tun, so viel ich weiß.
Okay. Herr Maja, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich möchte über Ihren Familienstand etwas erfahren.
Ja, aber was hat das damit zu tun? Ich bin verheiratet.
Ja, wir möchten alles über Ihnen wissen, alles über Sie wissen.
Okay, wenn das helfen soll, dann gut.
Ja, und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ja, ich habe zwei Buben, sagt man im Deutschen.
Zwei?
Zwei Jungs, zwei Jungs.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ja, die sind gesund.
Okay.
Und sind Sie zusammen mit Ihrem Familie?
Oder mit Ihrem Vater?
Ja, nur mit meiner Frau. Die Kinder sind schon längst aus.
Und Sie sind Rentner?
Ja, ja, schon seit 20 Jahren.
Ich bin zwar jetzt 76, aber damals, ich hatte einen schweren Beruf im Bergwerk.
Und als Bergwerkarbeiter hatte man damals die Möglichkeit,
dass man früh pensioniert wird.
Und ich bin dann relativ früh in die Rente gegangen.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie dort arbeitet als Bergwerkarbeiter?
Das waren bestimmt nur 30 Jahre.
Okay. Herr Maia, rufen Sie?
Nein, ich raufen nicht.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nein, früher habe ich auch nicht geraucht. Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz selten.
Ich habe mich mal eingeladen, wenn ich zu Familienfeier bin.
Dann vielleicht mal Schlückchen Wein, aber sonst nicht.
Mit Drogen haben Sie nichts zu tun?
Nehm ich mal Land?
Drogen? Was machen Sie denn damit?
Gefährliche Drogen.
Zum Beispiel Kokain oder Heroin oder Mariona.
Woher soll ich die denn beziehen?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Okay Herr Maia.
Ich glaube, dass wir alles gesprochen haben.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, aber bitte finden Sie heraus,
warum ich plötzlich nicht mehr Schlucken kann, warum das wehtut.
Ja, Sie haben wichtige Beschwerden.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Wir werden alle Ihre Beschwerden gut investieren,
damit wir eine Ursache finden können.
Zuerst werde ich Ihnen die körperliche Untersuchung
dann würde ich operative diagnostische Massnahme durchführen.
Dann können wir Mitragetnisse widerspringen.
Ja klar, gerne.
Okay, warten Sie bitte hier.
Ich komme wieder.
Alles klar.
Wer ist die Moderator? Was machen wir jetzt?
Ich möchte Ihnen die anderen etwas fragen.
Seid Herr Gündus nicht hier?
Ja, hat jemand Fragen?
Ja, wo sind die?
Sie machen das genau?
Im Halsbereich?
Nein, genau in der Brust, mitten in der Brust,
nicht unter der Brust, auch nicht am Hals.
Das ist genau da hinter der Brust.
Ich habe Sie schon mal verschlucken.
Ob ich mich verschluckt habe?
Nein, damit habe ich eigentlich kein Problem.
Vielleicht haben Sie Probleme mit dem Wasser schlucken,
das Flüchtlings- keit schlucken?
Also ich kann eigentlich alles schlucken, das tut nur weh.
Auch bei Wasser.
Keine Schwierigkeit.
Das geht runter, aber das brennt wie Feuer.
Haben Sie dort geblieben?
Ja, wo Sie sagen, seitdem ich mit der Evokophen begonnen habe,
merke ich schon, vor allem nachts habe ich dann plötzlich
ein bisschen Säure im Mund.
Nehmen Sie dagegen etwas Medikament?
Mein Rheumatologe hatte gesagt,
wenn es mal weh tut,
soll ich mal, was hatte gesagt,
Romme präzise, oder so hat er mir aufgeschrieben.
Ja.
Nehmen Sie Cortison?
Wie viel Dosis nehmen Sie?
Momentan nehme ich, ich glaube,
das ist Prätnison,
nehme ich gerade 20 Milligramm am Tag ein.
Nehmen Sie, beleistet,
gleichzeitig auch irgendwelche Magenschutz-Tablete.
Sie benutzen, nehmen Sie, so seit gleichzeitig,
Cortison und Evoprophen.
Ja, ich nehme momentan Evoprophen und Cortison gleichzeitig ein.
Haben Sie keine Magenschmerzen?
Also so richtig Magenschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Nein.
Wie ist die Schmerzen?
Im Liegen oder vorne beugen,
verschlechtert oder gelindert?
Hat es mit der Lage nicht...
Ne, ne, also nur wenn ich schluppe,
schluppe ich mir das einfach in der Brust wehe.
Die in Ruhe habe ich keine Schmerzen,
habe ich auch nicht, nur wenn ich schluppe.
Ist die in einem Heiser?
Heiser, ne, Heiser bin ich nicht.
Haben Sie Schwellungen, wie jemand fragt?
Ja, mit Lehmknoten.
Oder Lehmknoten im Hansbereich?
Also, Schwellungen habe ich jetzt nicht bemerkt, nein.
Haben Sie, Herr Rorschiff,
ich war den ersten Mal in der Erste.
Diese Frage.
Können Sie die Frage wiederholen?
Ja, zum ersten Mal.
Ja, das ist das erste Mal, das ist wichtig.
Das war alles, ich glaube.
Auch, wenn Sie mich schluppen möchten,
Sie haben das auch empfandelt.
Ja, mit dem Arztarsgeschenk, okay.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen
und wenn Sie Zeit hätten, würde ich gerne Ihnen vorstellen.
Ja, gerne.
Ja, Hermaja ist 76 Jahre alt,
172 cm groß und 70 kg schwer.
Er hat sich bei uns wegen seit einer Woche bestehender,
brennender Schmerzen im Hansbereich,
beim Schlücken, beim Schlücken vorgestellt.
Er hat diese Beschwerden zum ersten Mal.
Die Schmerzen sind auf einer Skala,
liegt zwischen 76 und 70.
Diese Schmerzen hat eine brennende Charakter.
Er hat keine Appetitlosigkeit,
aber in einer Woche hat er 6 kg abgenommen.
Diese Schmerzen liegt mitten in der Brust.
Er hat kein Fieber, kein Nachtschweiß,
keine Schlafstörungen und auch wichtig,
er hat seit 10 Tagen Melena im Stür.
Und aktuelle Beschwerden sind so,
als Vorerkrankungen, leider seit Jahren
Anromatöytatri, dagegen nimmt er seit 3 Monaten
eine kurze Zolltablitze,
etwa 20 mg pro Tag.
Und auch bei Bedarf,
Ibuprofen, als Schmerzmitten.
Bei diesem Medikament sind seine Beschwerden,
seine Schmerzen beim Schlücken geht besser.
Er würde nicht operiert zuvor.
Er leidet an allergenklinik und konjunktivit im Frühjahr,
dagegen nimmt er Tablet.
In der Familiengeschichte gibt es keine wichtige Erkrankung.
Die Mutter ist an einer lungenden Entzündung verstorben,
der Vater ist an einer Schlaganfall verstorben.
Er hat nie Maske raus, er trinkt sehr selten Alkohol,
er nimmt keine Drogen.
Er hat als Werkarbeiter für 30 Jahre gearbeitet
und er ist jetzt im Rente.
Die Beschwerden sind so, diese Geschichte ist so.
Und was machen wir jetzt mit dem?
Ich habe eine Verdachtdiagnose,
ich denke an Özophagus Kalzinum.
Der Patient hat Schmerzen beim Schlücken,
er hat eine wichtige Gewichtverlust in einer kurzen Zeit.
Er ist alt, er hat viele Risikofaktoren.
In der Familiengeschichte gibt es keine Krebsgeschichte,
aber diese Geschichte spricht eh über Krebs.
In dem, was Sie erzählt haben,
habe ich jetzt aber keine Risikofaktoren gesehen für Özophagus Krebs.
Ja, nur alter, nur alter, ja.
Nur alter.
Er raucht nicht.
Der raucht nicht, der trinkt auch kein Alkohol,
der nur ganz sporadisch.
Und Özophagus Kalzinum ist ja meistens entweder mit Alkohol
oder mit Rauchen für Gesellschaft.
Gut, ja, ob das jetzt ein Kalzinum ist,
müssen wir erst mal beweisen.
Aber Tatsache ist, der hat Schmerzen beim Schlücken
und so wie es aussieht, hat er auch Terstuhl.
Also, was machen Sie jetzt mit dem?
Ich würde so erst den Patienten körpferlich untersuchen,
ob es eine Liebknoten gibt oder gibt es wichtige,
wichtige Gefunde, oder Befunde gibt.
Dann würde ich aparative diagnostische Massnahme durchführen.
Ich würde endoscopic durchführen.
Wir können einfach sehen, ob es ein Problem in Özophagus gibt
und ob diese Melena von diesem Problem verursacht wird.
Wir können auch MRT durchführen.
Was machen wir denn jetzt zuerst?
Man kann ja vieles machen.
Man kann auch ein PET-CT machen.
Muss man das dann machen?
Ja, beide endoscopie.
Wir können eine Bio-C machen,
damit wir verstehen, ob es ein Krebs gibt.
Fangen wir doch beim Kleinen an.
Wir haben ihn körperlich untersucht.
Sie haben eine kleine Entschließung,
und sie haben keine Lymphknoten und keine Auffälligkeiten.
Sie haben auch einen Oberbaubereich palpiert.
Sie haben keinen Schmerz auslösen können.
Was ist der nächste Schritt, wenn jemand in den Notaufnahmen kommt?
Sie nehmen den Blut ab.
Ja, wir können sofort blutabieren.
Sie gucken, ob das tatsächlich Melena oder Retterstuhl war.
Sie können das daran sehen, ob jemand ein HB-Abfall hat.
Sie gucken, was sein Hemoglobin macht.
Ob Blutbildveränderungen da sind,
ob Transaminasen verändert sind.
Dann können sie irgendwelche Verdachten machen.
Das ist eine sehr große Frage.
Sie können auch eine L-D-H-Veränderung verbunden.
Sie können das auch daran erkennen.
Ich vermute, dass da etwas in diese Richtung besteht.
Aber Sie haben ihn noch nicht untersucht.
Gleich von Krebs zu sprechen, ist ein bisschen zu früh.
Aber Sie können natürlich in alle Richtungen denken.
Ich muss mich noch einmal auf die Frage stellen.
Wenn jemand mit solchen Beschwerden kommt,
haben Sie den körperlich untersucht.
Sie haben Blut abgenommen.
Gewöhnlich macht man einen Ultraschall.
Was ist da los?
Hat da irgendwelche Auffälligkeiten im Oberbaubaufbereich?
Was sehe ich da in der Leber?
Da kann zum Beispiel auch eine Leberzerose sein.
Im Rahmen der Leberzerose kann es auch eine Gastropathie geben.
Oder Ösofabrosvarizen geben.
Die können dann auch mal solche Beschwerden machen.
Deshalb machen Sie schnell einen Ultraschall.
Das ist nicht invasiv.
Das ist etwas, das sehr einfach durchzuführen.
Wir haben auch eine Leberzerose.
Wir haben aber Blut abgenommen.
Dann haben Sie gesehen, der hat tatsächlich ein HB-Abfall auf 11,1.
Die LDH ist eigentlich normal.
CRP ist minimal erhöht.
In manchen Laboren sagen wir mal auf 3.
In anderen Laboren auf 30.
Jetzt müssen Sie entscheiden, was mit dem zu tun ist.
Wir müssen prüfern, ob es eine richtige Melena ist.
Richtig.
Was machen Sie mit dem?
Sie können die Melena relativ schnell überprüfen.
Und als Dienstabenderarzt in der Notaufnahme
müssen das relativ schnell machen.
Eine rektal digitale Untersuchung.
Wir müssen wissen, ob die Angaben des Patienten stimmen oder nicht.
Hat der akut Melena oder keine Melena?
Wir haben eine rektale Untersuchung.
Man sagt, kein Terrestool am Fingerling.
Das ist der Begriff, den man benutzt.
Sie machen rektal digital.
Dann sagen Sie dem Oberarzt, rektal digitale Untersuchung war unauffällig.
Ich habe kein Terrestool am Fingerling gehabt.
Dann haben Sie erstmal ein bisschen Ruhe.
Anhand der Melena müssen Sie entscheiden,
ob jemand sehr früh gastroskopiert werden muss.
Oder ob man damit Zeit hat.
Wenn jemand akut blutet und hat einen starken HB-Abfall,
dann müssen Sie den notfallmäßig gastroskopieren.
Für diese Entscheidung brauchen Sie den HB-Wert.
Sie brauchen die klinische körperliche Untersuchung.
Ob rektal digital Terrestool da ist,
ob der HB-Wert relativ niedrig ist,
ob der Patient z.B. kreislaufproblematisch ist oder nicht.
Anhand dieser Faktoren entscheiden Sie,
ob der Akut eine Endoskopie braucht oder nicht.
Aber dieser Patient, den geht gut.
Der hat einen HB-Wert von 11 und hat keinen Terrestool am Fingerling.
Sie können mit der Endoskopie etwas warten.
Aber, das heißt ein bisschen warten,
machen Sie zunächst etwas anderes
oder würden Sie bei dem gleiche Endoskopie anschließen?
Wir können den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ja, würde ich schon machen.
Ja.
Und an den Monitor schließen.
Warum?
Wenn er schwere Blutungen hat, wir können.
Ja, glaube ich nicht.
Der HB-Wert ist ja 11 und Sie haben keinen Terrestool am Fingerling.
Dann müssen Sie den auch nicht an den Monitor nehmen.
Der ist kreislaufstabil.
Also den kann man auf Norma-Station tun.
Aber bevor Sie den auf Norma-Station tun,
können Sie die Infusion aufnehmen.
Ja, er kann nichts essen.
Wir können Infusion geben.
Ja, was geben Sie ihm?
Was geben Sie ihm Infusion?
Der Schritt in der Notaufnahme bei solchen Patienten
ist, dass sie dem natürlichen großlümigen Zulang legen.
Sprich keine blaue Braunüle,
keine rosane Braunüle.
Wenn Sie eine größere Orangepraunüle haben,
oder Sie können dem auch zwei grüne Braunülen legen,
mit der Überlegung, falls der mal akut stark blutet,
dann müssen Sie dem evtl. Blutkonserven anhängen.
Und da braucht man dann einen größeren Zugang.
Wenn Sie das gemacht haben, wäre der nächste Schritt,
dass Sie dem erstmal ein PPI anhängen.
Intervenös.
Er hat gesagt, dass er Omeprazol gegebenenfalls eingenommen hat.
Aber ob er das jetzt durchgehend genommen hat,
wissen wir nicht.
Aber wenn jemand den Verdacht aus einer oberen Geiblutung hat,
dann muss man dem Pantazol IV anhängen.
Nur Pantazol hat eben diese intravenöse Form.
Und dann hängen Sie dem mal 80 Milligramm Pantazol
als Kurzinfusion dran.
Falls der irgendwo ein Geschwür- oder ein Tumor hat,
damit die Säuremenge so ein bisschen reduziert ist.
Und damit der keine Übelkeit bekommt,
würde ich dem auch ein bisschen Wormax anhängen.
Also Dimend Vythrinat.
Und schauen, dass er dann also einigermaßen stabil ist.
Dann nehmen Sie den so auf Station und dem verordnen Sie auch fest
Magenschutz.
Das kann Pantazol sein.
Das kann Omeprazol sein.
Oder auch Nexium, was man mit der Weihlaubewahl hat.
Und dann klären Sie den aber tatsächlich für eine Endoskopie auf.
Das ist das aller, aller Nächste,
was auf jeden Fall gemacht werden muss.
Mit Bildgebung und so weiter würde ich mich erstmal nicht aufhalten,
sondern Sie machen tatsächlich am nächsten Tag
direkt die Magenspiegelung.
Sie gucken, was ist da los?
Blutet der Akut?
Oder ist das etwas anderes?
Hat der einen Tumor?
Dann kann man in der gleichen Sitzung auch daraus eine Probe nehmen.
Hat der keinen Tumor?
Dann nimmt man gegebenenfalls von auffälligen Lesionen-Proben
um zu schauen, was ist da genau los?
Sie klären den auf und dann nehmen Sie den Station herauf.
Wenn es jetzt ums Aufklärung geht,
haben Sie schon mal jemanden für eine Endoskopie aufgeklärt,
so eine obere gastrointestinale Untersuchung,
eine ÖGD, wie wir sagen, eine Magenspiegelung?
Noch nicht.
Noch nie aufgeklärt?
Nein.
Wir müssen natürlich wissen, wie so eine Untersuchung abläuft.
Das kann natürlich auch genau gefragt werden.
Wie läuft das dann ab?
Wie läuft denn so eine Magenspiegelung ab?
Kann ja mal einen Prüfer fragen.
Dafür müssen Sie natürlich wissen,
dass der Patient nüchtern bleiben muss.
Er konnte zwar nicht schlucken,
aber für die Untersuchung müssen Sie den nüchtern lassen.
Der darf jetzt am nächsten Morgen bis zur Untersuchung
nichts essen, nichts trinken.
Weil er nichts trinken kann,
hängen Sie dem oder ordnen dem auf der Station ein bisschen Infusion an.
Das kann ionosteril sein, das kann auch NACL sein.
Wichtig ist, dass sein Kreislauf nicht darunter leitet.
Eine Magenspiegelung läuft mit einem Endoskop ab.
Der Aufbau eines Endoskops besteht ja aus,
ich sage immer, drei Kanälen.
Man hat eine Lichtquelle,
man hat einen Arbeitskanal
und man hat einen Videokopf am Endoskop,
damit so drei Ausgänger.
Warum Licht?
Damit man natürlich alles ausleuchten kann,
sagt man, damit man alles gut sehen kann.
Und die Kamera, nun weil der Arzt an einem Fernseher-Monitor
alles gut beobachtet und beurteilen möchte.
Und der dritte Kanal ist dafür da,
falls er mal irgendwelche Proben nehmen will,
dann kann er da drüber feinste Werkzeuge vorschieben
und mit einer Zange oder mit einer Pinzette
aus der betroffenen Stelle eine kleine Probe rausholen.
Das ist der Ablauf der Untersuchung.
Man geht durch den Mund über die Speiseröhre
bis in den Magen und sogar weiter bis zum Dodenum
und guckt sich alles genauestens an.
Dieses Endoskop hängt an solchen Zahnrädern,
wie man sagt, so Seilen.
Die kann man dann durch hin und her drehen,
in die gewünschten Richtungen drehen,
sodass man auch 360 Grad überall reingucken kann.
Und dann sieht man auch, was alles auffällig ist oder nicht.
Das ist die Untersuchung.
Was Sie bei der Untersuchung berücksichtigen müssen,
Sie müssen den Patienten die Untersuchung erklären.
Aber auch darauf hinweisen, welche Gefahren dabei bestehen.
Damit die Leute den Endoskop nicht zerbeißen,
nicht kaputt machen, gibt es einen sogenannten Beißring.
Bevor die Untersuchung beginnt,
kriegen die das in den Mund,
die beißen da draußen,
dann hat man einen Zugang durch den Mund
und dann wird dieser Schlauch langsam in den Rachen vorgeschoben.
Wenn man so ein festes Ding durch den Mund bis in den Magen vorschiebt,
verletzt man Schleimhaut.
Oder der Patient toleriert meistens die Untersuchung nicht,
dann kriegen die etwas zum Sedieren, Dormikon
oder vielleicht Kropofol, je nachdem, wer mit Wasser arbeitet.
Und dann können die auch dabei mal so fest zudrücken,
drauf beißen, dass der Endoskop tatsächlich kaputt geht.
Und man kann dabei auch Zähne kaputt machen.
Man kann tatsächlich Blutungen provozieren.
Und wenn man sehr, sehr unvorsichtig ist
und der Patient bewegt sich während der Untersuchung,
kann man sogar die Speiseröhre damit zuverletzen,
dass man auch eine Perforation hervorrufen kann.
Bis hin zu einer Mediascinitis
oder aber auch eine Magenperforation,
die im schlimmsten Fall auch operiert werden muss.
Oder, was auch die Lehmlich-Map passiert ist,
dass der Patient während der Untersuchung aspiriert
oder aber auch respiratorisch insoffizient ist.
Und all diese Gefahren müssen Sie in der Aufklärung
schon in der Notaufnahme den Patienten erklären.
Und dann müssen Sie das unterschreiben lassen.
Und dann nienen Sie ihn stationär auf.
Jetzt haben da die Kollegen aufgeschrieben,
ja, Breischluck ist zwar richtig,
aber ich würde das nicht jetzt direkt machen,
sondern meiner Meinung nach ist der erste Schritt
erstmal die ÖGD, die Magenspielung.
Und wenn man da nichts findet,
dann kann man mit Breischluck zum Beispiel schauen,
ob es eine Motilitätsstörung gibt.
Aber das ist nicht der erste Schritt.
Jetzt haben Sie den ausgenommen,
wir haben den Flüssigkeit gegeben,
ob jetzt Glupose 5 oder ob Sie jetzt
noch Steril gegeben haben.
Sie haben ihn jetzt Versorgung auf Station geschickt
und der wird jetzt am nächsten Tag in die Endoskopie abgerufen.
Jetzt läuft die Untersuchung
und jetzt sind wir gespannt,
was der Endoskopiker oder der Gastroenterologe dabei sieht.
Er sagt, runter in die Speiseröhre,
kurz vor dem suffagogastralen Übergang,
sieht man einen Sorgefall.
Man sieht einen richtigen Pilzbefall der Speiseröhre,
der zirkulär die gesamte Zirkumferenz eingenommen hat.
Darüber hinaus im Bereich des suffagogastralen Überganges
deutliche streitige Lesionen
und weiter unten im Magen
sagt er erosive Gastritis
und teilweise so streifig erosiv
und man kann jetzt vermuten, was der Patient jetzt hat.
Aber in den Tumor sieht der Patient jetzt nicht.
Ja, man kann an Kandidat Özövagitis denken.
Ja, ist ja.
Er hat einen Sorgefall, also es ist ein Kandidat Özövagitis.
Wie kommt denn so etwas zustande?
In dieser Stande wie Immunespression.
Ja, und bei den Patienten ist das ja eigentlich ein Leuchttin.
Warum ist das bei ihm ein Stand?
Cortison, genau so, darauf wollte ich nämlich hinaus
nicht immer gleich an Tumor denken,
sondern wenn Patienten so schmerzhafte Schluckstörungen angeben,
dann können es auch mal unter Immunsuppressiva zu einem
zu einer Sorgösophagitis kommen.
Und er hat schon angegeben, er hat zwei Sachen auf einmal genommen.
Er hat Steroide genommen, er hat NSA-R eingenommen,
das NSA-R und auch das Steroid können natürlich
zu einem Stressulkuss führen
oder aber zumindest zu einer erosiven Gastritis.
Wenn der Patient seine PPI-Therapie nicht regulär eingenommen hat.
So, jetzt haben sie die Diagnose, der hat keinen Krebs,
der hat aber eine Sorgösophagitis
und der hat eine erosive Gastritis.
Und was ist jetzt die Therapie bei dem?
Bei der erosiven Gastritis,
der Patient müssen PPI benutzen.
Was geben Sie da, den einen Namen sollten Sie schon kennen?
Da hat jemand das schon hingeschrieben.
Nein, das nicht, das untere.
Amphomoronal nennt sich das.
Das ist Amphoterizin.
Amphototeroid, das ist der Amphotorin.
Amphototeroid, das ist der Amphoteroid.
Das ist der Amphoteroid.
Amphoterizin ist Amphomoronal.
Das gibt es in zwei Formen.
In Deutschland entweder in Form von Suspension
oder aber in Form von Lutschtabletten.
Die wirksame Dosis ist,
dass man entweder zwei Pipetten nimmt,
viermal am Tag,
oder aber viermal Lutschtabletten.
Das ist ein Lutschtabletten.
Das können Prüfer fragen.
Die Lutschtabletten oder aber die Suspension.
Wie nimmt man das ein?
Das sollten Sie beherrschen.
Die Suspension nehmen Sie immer nach dem Essen ein.
Zwei Pipetten in den Mund.
Und so ca. 5 Minuten Gurgeln im Mund.
Und runter schlucken.
Nicht wie andere Sachen ausspucken,
sondern Gurgeln und runter schlucken.
Und dann sagt man,
so ca. eine halbe Stunde,
30 Minuten lang,
nicht essen, nichts trinken.
Damit das Medikament die betroffenen Areale
wie ein Schmerzfilm umgibt
und seine Wirkung entfalten kann.
Das Gleiche passiert auch mit den Lutschtabletten.
Sie zergehen, runter schlucken
und eine halbe Stunde lang nichts essen, nichts trinken.
Dreimal nach dem Essen und einmal vor dem Schlafen gehen.
Dann hat man viermal am Tag genommen.
Intravenös wirkt da nicht.
Das ist eine Lokaltherapie.
Das kann manchmal in der
45 Tage besser werden.
Das kann manchmal auch einige Wochen anhalten.
Das muss man abhängig von der Symptomatik machen.
Wenn der Patient, aber meistens sagen die Patienten,
die ich so kenne, innerhalb von 2-3 Tagen
haben die Schmerzen schon nachgelassen.
Und PPE bei der erosiven Gas-Fitness,
was würden Sie da geben?
Panthopasol und Romaplazoin.
Das dürfen Sie wählen, wie Sie wollen.
Aber es geht mir nur um die Dosis.
Das ist das Wichtige.
40 mg, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Die Standarddosis sind der 20 mg.
Man sagt, bei so einer schweren erosiven Gas-Fitness
würde ich mindestens so für 14 Tage
doppelte Standarddosis 2-mal geben.
Also 2-mal 40 mg würde ich dem dann für 2 Wochen geben.
Und dann kann man das reduzieren.
Manche empfehlen sogar,
wenn das Ganze nicht so richtig abklinkt,
die Beschwerden, dass man in 4 Wochen
nochmal die Endoskopie wiederholt.
Danke für das Einsehen.
Soweit verstanden, wie man mit solchen Fällen
in der Notaufnahme notfallmäßig umgeht,
was man da alles berücksichtigen muss
und welche Untersuchungen als allererstes notwendig sind.
Wie Sie gesehen haben, brauchen wir auch keinen Breitschluck,
wir brauchen auch keine Bildgebung.
Und wie lange würden Sie jetzt solch einen Patienten
stationär behalten?
Wie lange kann der Patient essen?
Nein, müssen Sie nicht.
Sie haben die Diagnose gestellt,
Sie haben die Therapie begonnen.
Und am nächsten Tag, nicht gleich am Tag der Magenspiegelung
der Endoskopie, sondern einen Tag, 2 Tage danach,
können Sie ihn schon wieder entlassen.
Er muss nicht stationär bleiben.
Er hat keine aktive Blutungsquelle.
Er hat wahrscheinlich so Sickerblutungen gehabt
bei der erosiven Gastritis.
Der HB passt ja auch dazu, ist ja auch nicht sehr stark abgefallen.
Und dementsprechend haben Sie ihm jetzt
auch die Erosiven Gastritis.
Auch wenn er nichts essen kann.
Auch wenn er nichts essen kann, richtig.
Aber wie gesagt, mit dem Amphomoral
werden die Beschwerden relativ rasch besser.
Meine Beobachtung ist, dass die Patienten
so 2. oder 3. Tag gleich sagen,
ja, ich kann wieder schlucken, auch wenn das noch ein bisschen weh tut.
Aber es ist bei Weitem nicht mehr so wie früher.
In der Türkei gibt es keine Orale
oder Lufttablette
für die Amphotelesin.
Deswegen verschreiben wir
Mr. Thin
oder alles.
Wie gesagt, wir sind hier in Deutschland
und wir müssen hier die Standards in Deutschland lernen.
Die Türkei müssen wir jetzt vergessen.
Sie müssen hier die Vorgehensweise wiedergeben.
Mr. Thin ist zwar ein gutes Medikament,
aber wie gesagt in den Leitlinien,
wenn man hier guckt, ist Mr. Thin
wahrscheinlich relativ spät.
Er ist auch geführt als Möglichkeit,
aber in erster Linie wird Amphomoral
und Amphoterezin erst mal angewendet.
Für andere Erkrankungen wie Puteo- myoleusche Leukämie
und so weiter gibt es noch andere Medikamente.
Aber Amphomoral ist das Medikament erwartet.
Wie lange dauert die Therapie?
Wie gesagt, das kann bei manchen Leuten
innerhalb von einer Woche, zehn Tage wieder komplett weggehen.
Bei dem anderen, wenn zum Beispiel
die Cortisontherapie weiter fortgeführt werden muss,
kann es auch einige Wochen dauern.
Das ergibt von jedem Menschen unterschiedlich aus.
Es gibt auch andere,
die einen besonderen Nebenwirkung haben,
wie die Anwendung.
Bei den Intervenösen,
warum wollen Sie unbedingt den Intervenösen geben?
Nein, ich meine, ich möchte fragen,
gibt es besondere Nebenwirkungen
bei Oral Anwendung?
Überhaupt nicht.
Das wird kaum resuppiert.
Das wird nur lokal aus der Oberfläche.
Und zwar dort, wo dieser Sorgefall ist.
Das macht kaum Nebenwirkungen.
Das ist auch gut, warum?
Weil das Medikament auch teilweise den Pilzbefall in Darm mitbekämmt.
Leute, die einen Sorgefall der Speiseröhre haben,
können auch mal enteralen Sorgefall haben.
Auch dort wirft es gut.
Es wird nicht resuppiert.
Wenn dann überhaupt nur ganz minimal so Nebenwirkungen,
wüsste ich jetzt nicht,
habe ich bei keinem meiner Patienten beobachtet bisher.
Ich glaube, dass wir alles erzählt haben.
Wir haben viele gelernt.
Okay, hoffentlich.
Bitte.
Möchtest du jemanden fragen?
Nein, ich stehe jetzt.
Alles klar.
Wollen wir dann die Sitzung damit beenden?
Ja, vielen Dank.
Alles klar.
Tschüss.